we are all writers now whether you want
to write a book
or a blog or better text messages or
emails i want to help you with a free
ebook
called 11 ways to write better you can
find that
at theminimalists.com resources
enjoy minimalists
jess says what does rob bell think about
the afterlife
think about the afterlife i have no idea
if rob believes in an afterlife
i find it absolutely impossible to
believe
that this experience that you are having
as a
sole essence in a body
is confined to this particular brief
years
of space in this space time continuum
yeah the idea
that it's over in like
uh 77 years in this body and that the
soul
which never stops telling you how
indestructible and infinite and eternal
it is
is suddenly like i guess i'm out too uh
i just find that impossible
is this the finding it impossible and
that this isn't accusatory
we're just having a conversation of
course but could that be coming from the
ego at all like the fact that that the
ego refuses to believe that this is it
oh oh oh oh uh i'm just curious
oh of course i'm just noting
all the near-death experiences yeah all
of the experiences
of altered states in all their shapes
and forms
all of the traditions of the wise ones
who spoke of an eternal now um
just the fact that for many people the
body
is the outer boundary of the person so
um this is the this is the outline of
ryan and then
in ryan might be a soul or spirit so we
don't know yeah
um but some energy if you would have
loved to be here today but couldn't make
it you would have said to me hey
i'm with you in spirit yeah so right
there
or the people we've lost that we loved
that are gone and we talk about there's
they're still with us
so your body is not the outer boundary
of who you are
your body is something happening within
the larger phenomenon that is you
mm-hmm you know it's so oh good
so whatever it is that is of your
essence or your essence
we already have a lived experience that
it isn't contained in simply this
physical structure so the fact that
pretty much every ancient wisdom
tradition
was like yeah this this is like first
round or
had some language to talk about the
boundlessness
of your true self um
on the on the eternal now i mean because
i
yeah the way i visualize that is the x
and y axis
um which is a rather crucial z-axis
trace and i love talking about this i
just looked over at him like oh this is
like he just put the ball on the tee
yeah well okay so if you go up on an
airplane and i'm on the ground
and we're both wearing watches your
watch will run faster than mine
so you go live on a mountain i live in
the valley you will live
more years in the same amount of years
because time
travels faster farther from the earth
the higher up you are the faster a clock
runs
so time is actually bendy stretchy
relative and there is no now because if
you ask me what am i doing right now
and you are observing me and then
reporting and telling him what i'm doing
now
what i'm doing now would have to light
would have to bounce off your light
cones which take a couple milliseconds
so you would be describing what i was
doing a couple milliseconds ago
so there's only now all of your memories
can only take place
right now and all of your thoughts about
the future can only take place right now
so there only actually is
a now and the only thing that goes on
forever is the present
so time is actually a persistent
illusion
it's not set because you have your app
on your computer you have that those
squares that tell you the days
like they're they're 24 hour particular
chunks
but that's actually like saying that the
earth is flat because when i walk out of
this office building it'll be flat it's
actually round
and what's going to happen in the next i
would argue 25 years is people are going
to realize the way they've been thinking
about the time
time is exactly how people thought about
a flat earth look it's flat
actually it's round and people are going
to realize this whole time construction
isn't real how's that that's here's what
i mean i would just
regret is when you're stuck in the past
worry is when you're stuck in the future
but you can only ever be in the presence
so those are
actually fabrications they have no
essence or materiality to them
right worry and great are actually
illusions
and which is why every single wisdom
tradition is always about being here
there's a lovely tweetable so there's
time yeah there's a bit on time
and i actually think let's move it in i
think the next couple of years
you're going to start to see
massive numbers of people realizing that
time
is fundamentally different than what i
thought it was and i think covet is a
massive part of it because people are
working from home
and they're getting way way way more
done in these
much less time or even if i talk to you
about november right
now november is a concept at this point
if i ask you about last may
right think of how it's messed with your
sense of what a year
2020 just just warped
so much of this so yeah this
understanding and like you have carlos
ravelli and all sorts of wonderful
theoretical physicists and scientists
writing about actually time is
way weirder than any of us thought um
yeah yeah
those are fun you begin to live with
this it it shapes you in all sorts of
ways
yeah those are fun little thought
experiments i love it your smile is
fantastic
well i'm thinking my daughter the other
day she said um
just out of nowhere she said five weeks
is three weeks yes
and she's seven but like for to me that
captured in a
moment exactly what we're feeling right
now
yeah yeah and then you think about like
like your listeners your moments of
greatest joy
in life are always moments
when you are caught up in a loss of time
they generally involve some loss
of a recognition of the passing of time
i don't know where the time went
when i do this um time
flies yeah so you realize that this is
actually
we have a lot more to play with
in time than we first realized
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah this is joy you
have to plug
uh an intro to joy ah yes
um man uh i brought sean my wife was out
of town to go see the
the live talk that you did a little
community theater in
west hollywood when you were first i
think you were just telling me yeah
yeah yeah and then um i shared it with
my wife
um when you put it out on youtube which
i'll put a link to it in the show notes
if folks want to check it out and you
definitely should it's
it's truly phenomenal man like it's oh
thank you
uh and i i it's a comedy special
it's a sermon it's um
it's um we're all gonna a lecture
yeah it's a pep talk
it's all of these things and really none
of these
things because those are just labels
it's
uh an hour or so by the way time just
sort of disappeared when we were
watching
and the next day you know bex who has no
religious inclinations at all um she's
sending it like to all her family and
friends you gotta check this out and
um i was just i was really fascinated
with what you did from
that first time you did it and until you
had a sort of
you know finished product um um yeah
congratulations though thank you you saw
one of the yeah
that was the first time i've ever done
like rehearsal shows and then
you take it out and take it around the
world and it starts to get
something yeah yeah it's really fun yeah
yeah that film
the the temporal passing fragile nature
of life we're all gonna die maybe soon
so that's where you find the joy
joy is very different than happy happy's
the binary was sad
same as pessimist is different than
optimist like the but joy is completely
different
it wraps its arms around the full
spectrum of the human experience it can
handle it all